بعد عده اسابيع على اختفائها عن وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي عادت قصه الفنانه
المصريه شيرين عبد الوهاب الى الواجهه
مجددا ذلك بعد ان كشف ايهاب صالح مدير
اعمالها مفاجاه جديده اكد فيها ان حسابات
شيرين على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لا
تدار من قبلها منذ بدايه العالم ولو كان
الامر عائدا لها لنشر كل شيء على صفحتها
وكانت قد انتشرت الشهر الماضي شائعات تفيد
بانفصالها عن زوجها حسام حبيب لا سيما وسط
اختفائها عن وسائل التواصل كليا
لكن الفنانه المصريه نفت تلك الانباء في
بيانا صدر عن محاميها واكدت حينها انا
مشغوله في اعداد اغاني جديده بعد انتهت من
البومها الاخير
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات